let's bring in Gary parish CBS sports
college basketball columnist TV analyst
who joins us now Gary good morning how
are you okay yeah you just play I mean
that's you just once once you throw the
ball up Gary then I play that's it I've
been through it so good luck but you'll
you'll you'll make it through thank you
Gary thank you all right most likely to
be traded tonight is who I wouldn't be
shocked if you know we see a whole lot
of movement among lottery picks I mean
they're you know you could see the
Sacramento Kings taking somebody at
number two and then immediately moving
him so that they can move down to maybe
select Michael Porter jr. a little lower
in the lottery so while it's been a
relatively calm past few days and weeks
I think now because there's so much
uncertainty basically 2 through 7 or 8
or 9 in the NBA Draft that you could see
any of these you know prospects walk
onto a stage put on a hat and then
immediately have to take that hat off to
put on a different jeans act I mentioned
this that this started the show with an
NFL pick I'll give a 3-year window
before you truly assess the value or you
know if the team did well or the player
it feels like what the NBA it's almost a
five year window to be fair to them
because I would have looked at Victor
Oladipo and said he was a bust
but now five years out I'm looking back
and Victor Oladipo certainly not a bust
Anthony Bennett we know is a bust these
kids are 18 and 19 Gary it's it's
getting harder and harder to project how
good they're going to be and when
they're going to be good
well that's exactly the reason it's
because in the NFL you're you're largely
drafting 21 22 year olds sometimes even
older and in the NBA certainly in the
lottery you drafting a 19 year old
sometimes and this will happen tonight
an 18 year old and so I always find it
interesting that leading up to the draft
we're talking about these prospects in
absolute terms like this guys you
guaranteed to be a star this guy is not
going to be much and yet we're surprised
every single year because as good as the
people running these franchises are and
as much energy and
and in time is spent evaluating the
prospect it's still very much a hit or
miss game you can look at any lottery
from in a year and there are guys that
we all thought would be great who just
aren't and guys that we didn't see
greatness in them who turned into
something relevant the NBA it's it's not
easy doing the job that that these
people are asked to do tonight the
player with the least question marks is
who I think probably Luca dont't just
because we've seen him play against
grown man for years now and you know
he's forests in in every setting and
he's got an undeniable skill set up you
know he can put them on the floor he can
pass and he can shoot I know that sounds
simple but like that is a valuable thing
in the modern NBA like can you dribble
pass into if so there's a place on the
court for you that that's the key to the
Warriors beyond just having you know
three or four the best players in the
world is that they often have four or
five guys on the court who can all
dribble pass and shoot and so I'm not
certain that doctors just got that the
highest ceiling but I do think you've
got the highest floor there's just no
way barring injury of course that he's
not going to be a relevant player
immediately and for a long long time
the player with the most question marks
I would say Mitchell Robinson you know
that's a guy who if you and I would have
been talking a year ago we would have
projected him as a lottery pick in the
2018 NBA Draft but he goes to Western
Kentucky enrolls withdrawal disappears
it ends up not playing college
basketball so there's question marks
about like his decision-making and the
people around them but also we haven't
seen him that the way we've seen Marvin
Bagley or DeAndre Aten in college but he
was you know talked about in in similar
circles you know Lee you know through
his prep career so I think somebody late
in the first round early in the second
round is going to be able to take a
swing on him and they could get a future
all-star because he is that talented or
they could get a guy who's not in the
league in four years because he does
have those kinds of questions attached
to him talking to Gary parish CBS sports
college basketball columnist analyst on
TV as well why do some of these players
not want to play in Memphis
you know it's it's tough to deal with I
live in Memphis I make it my home so
when you think one after another after
another refused to work out refused to
provide medical it does become a little
you know interesting but the the two
prospects that that's been attached to
jaren Jackson and Mohammad bomba I
actually think if you look at their
situations independently it sort of
makes sense so you know their range is
very small and so they could either one
go as highest you know three to the
Atlanta Hawks but they're not either one
dropping further than five six or seven
and when you look at some of the
franchises drafting in that range you
know it's it's it's the Dallas Mavericks
big market you know if it's the Chicago
Bulls big market and also opportunities
where you know they are going to be big
in this league and and and you can go
into those other franchises and sort of
be the focal point of that right from
the jump whereas if you go to Memphis
you know particularly in a league where
you can't hardly play too big at all
anymore you're you're playing behind
Marc Gasol immediately so I think some
of it is market size some of it is the
perception of the direction of the
franchise but some of it is those are
two bigs who don't want to play behind
Marc Gasol
so I understand it even if it's I know
it's frustrating for Memphian then in
the Grizzlies franchise where do you
stand on tre young I like him
you know he's got this one obvious
identifiable skill and that's his
ability to create shots and make shots
and so I understand the concerns you
know he's he's small on the small side
but I will say that though people
continue to point out he's smaller than
Steph Curry that's true at this moment
but 19 year old Trey young is not
smaller than 19 year old Steph Curry and
he had a better freshman season at
Oklahoma than Steph Curry had at
Davidson so I'm not projecting him to be
a the next Steph Curry because that's a
two-time MVP three-time world champion
I'm not rejecting anybody to be that but
I do think that you know you put the
ball in his hands and surround him with
with better talent than what he was able
to play with at Oklahoma and he's going
to be a high level NBA player
in fact like the circle back to the
Grizzlies assuming that DeAndre Aiden
Marvin Bagley Luka daunted her off the
board in some order one two three I
would seriously consider Trey young with
that four pick or seriously consider
moving down to get Trey young i i'm a
believer in him but I also think that we
talk ourselves into draft prospects and
we talk ourselves out of drought
prospects and certainly with it comes
down to this you see every NBA draft
well who's he gonna guard and if we said
that about Steph Curry which we did and
Steve Nash which we did at the top end
of this they couldn't guard anybody but
it's I need the ratio of what you're
gonna give me offensively to what you
give up defensively and Nash and Steph
Curry that ratio certainly leans in
their favor but with Trey young that's
my big concern is he gonna have enough
up side offensively that I don't care
how he is defensively where do you stand
on I think he's got the skill set to do
it and he certainly you know I think
this gets glossed over sometimes he did
things at the collegiate level that
literally had never been done by any
Division one player I don't care if
you're talking about Steph Curry James
Harden John Wall doesn't matter and so
you're exactly right like if you're good
enough on the offensive end if you know
we're willing to deal with it on the
defensive end evidence being James
Harden first team all-nba Damian Lillard
first team all-nba you know I get the
question all the time about Trey young
how's he gonna guard Russell Westbrook
well he's not gonna guard Russell
Westbrook nobody guards run Westbrook
you know can't he be special at
something and I think the way he's able
to comfortably shoot from basically
anywhere the way he has vision that
allows him to not only see opportunities
but then to create opportunities for for
his teammates or himself I just think
there's so much special stuff in those
areas that that I'm willing to overlook
or at least discount some of the obvious
deficiencies I know you do a great job
covering college basketball with the
one-and-done and the possibility of
maybe 2021 2022
how would you handicap what you think is
going to happen what will that mean for
a senior in high school and when well
it looks like it's going to be here
sooner rather than later and I think
that delay is to allow franchises to
prepare for that moment when they are
allowed to select a you know high school
graduate straight out of high school
once again which is something I've
always been for you know I will not like
not having the Anthony Davis's and the
Kevin Durant's and players of that level
you know in college because it's fun to
watch them it's fun to write about them
it's fun to talk about them but they
don't belong in college like there are
there is uniquely gifted and and
obviously capable of playing that sport
for a living so you know if somebody's
learned to draft them let's let's let
that happen and so you know impact
college basketball to some level and and
it'll impact the NBA undeniably but you
know the franchises will just have to be
in high school gyms once again and you
know playing the pros and cons of of
drafting somebody who may turn into a
star even if they don't help you
immediately but I go back to that window
we had there you know high school
players were getting drafted it starts
with Kevin Garnett and goes all the way
up right before the Greg Oden Kevin
Durant draft and if you put up because I
did a study on this once upon a time if
you would have simply walked to the
podium or had David Stern walk to the
podium for you every single year in that
range and said I will take best high
school player available you would have
had the best roster in the NBA by a wide
margin so the hit rate on those guys was
pretty remarkable and I think you'll see
you'll see NBA franchises starting to
lean that direction just as soon as
they're allowed to Gary good stuff we
appreciate your time thanks for joining
us that's our Gary Parrish CBS sports
college basketball analyst for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
you
[Music]